tatiana mislani is calling out the use
of the label's strong female lead ahead
of her highly anticipated role as
jennifer walters in the upcoming disney
plus series she hulk attorney at law
[Music]
yeah speaking with the guardian tatiana
says the term is irritating because it's
reductive adding it's just as much as
shaving off of all the nuances and just
as much of a trope it's a box that
nobody fits into even the phrase is
frustrating it's as if we're supposed to
be grateful that we get to be that the
canadian-born star also said that she's
hopeful there will be a day when a
female playing a superhero is no longer
a big deal explaining i'm really
interested in when these marginalized
voices get to speak without it being
like oh my god it's all women or oh my
god this is a story about a queer couple
and those stories become as innately
expected as they are now special i'm
here for that i like that a lot
we've talked a lot in the last few years
about the idea that yes we want to
celebrate uh people's differences and
celebrate people's points of view but we
want to also get to a point where um
diverse voices
where it's not something that is seen as
special because it's rare where is
expected and it's a normal part of
discourse and a normal part of
entertainment
yeah no i definitely agree with that and
there's a lot of instances even on this
show where i've been like really this is
what we're talking about in 2022 like
this shouldn't be news this should be an
everyday thing why are we not you know
normalizing this and and in our
conversations but at the same time and i
do agree with her and what she said but
at the same time the reality is we
aren't there yet and
unfortunately you know there are people
with some really dated mindsets and it
takes all of us
coming together and kind of breaking um
those norms that other people have like
saying strong female lead yeah like just
you know me and you that's a statement
that doesn't need said but there are
plenty of people who you kind of have to
put that label on certain things for
them to even realize um that women are
still
treated second
you know and i feel that way about about
you know racism and discrimination as
well i think sometimes it's like yeah
why are we saying the first uh you know
gay marriage
in 20 whatever it's like what how how is
that a thing
it's like we should all be inclusive and
and and uh you know equal but at the
same time
sometimes we do have to pinpoint that
stuff to get people to catch up
so i i agree but at the same time we're
not there yet and it takes sometimes i'm
not saying this is gonna save everyone
but
it's moments like this when we are
mindful that you know there is a lot of
um
issues with balance in in media and with
celebrities and whatnot in movies and in
the world and whatever that we need to
kind of balance things yeah yeah you
know there's it's interesting to when
you apply this to like the fandom of
marvel stuff and star wars stuff because
there's a certain segment of that fandom
that gives the rest of us a really bad
rap and it's this segment that says that
you know that they're overly critical of
um
any of the shows that are female-led or
that are diverse or that are led by
people other than what they think you
know the traditional superhero should be
like and they're very vocal and they
talk about it a lot and it's really it's
i was gonna say bothersome but that's
that's putting it very very very lightly
it's it's awful um and i think those
people really need to be checked when
they are out there talking like that um
you know i've gotten a chance to see the
first few episodes of she-hulk attorney
at law and i'm not going to give
anything away here i can't really talk
about it too much but i will say that
they do address that kind of head on
which i think is very cool
and they do in a very very cool way